So the answer no is something we cannot obtain in finite time
and that is why the Halting Problem is called semi-decidable,
because we can kind of decide half of the answers
and it's also called undecidable
because we cannot output a clear yes or no
after a finite amount of time.
Why this nit-picking; what's the difference, you might ask.
The interest of this, of course, is rather theoretic,
but semi-decidable problems
have a very interesting property called recursive enumerability.
Now that sounds a bit strange; what does that mean?
Recursive enumerability means that you can
write a program that outputs all combinations
of inputs and programs, and I seriously mean
all combinations of inputs and programs
that halt.
So this program here cannot say
for any input and program that this combination will not halt
but it can output a complete list
of inputs and programs that will halt,
so let's have a look at this program,
and of course, this program runs on infinitely,
so it start off by defining a length called max length
to be 0
and then it goes into an infinite loop, which is this one here,
and what it does then is it increases max length
by one each time it goes into this loop here,
enumerates all programs of length at most max length.
Now if you fix this max length here,
there is a huge number of programs
that have a length at most max length
but it's finite; it's huge but finite,
and the same goes for the inputs.
So for all combinations of programs and inputs
that are shorter than this value max length here,
we run a simulation for exactly max length steps
and if the program halts on the input
after exactly max length steps,
then we print the program, and we print the input.
If it hasn't halted yet,
don't care, throw it away, wait until the next loop.